Hello, brother.
I can't do this, Stefan.
Incendia!
No!
Stefan, I love you.
Something's wrong.
-With Elena?
-With me.
Kiss me.
Damon is not stable
right now.
You know he murdered
my wife?
All right, let's go.
Clothes on.
Jeremy wrote this?
I'm not playing anymore.
I said get out!
Hello, Elena.
Hell, I can take down
a vampire.
That spell is easy to learn.
I know that I'm…
I'm falling in love.
Stefan didn't drink
the papal blood.
If you were curious.
The moon stone, Stefan.
Tick tock.
Just a taste.
No, no! No, Mumma!
I don't want you
to be alone.
-Katerina.
-No.
You may be my father,
but I am never going to be
your daughter, you got that?
Stefan Salvatore, I hereby
invite you into this home.
Damon, I'll do better,
I promise.
No.
You know where the witches
were burned?
Did I forget
to mention that?
You're going to have to hit
me a lot harder than that.
He is human.
A life means nothing.
Damon, no!
For me, it’s the end.
Take it.
It's his signature.
There's a reason
they call him the Ripper.
A fatal werewolf bite.
Ouch.
Forget Stefan.
I'm so much more fun.
You are supposed to be dead.
Take it easy.
We both know you're
kind of a lightweight.
OK, please tell me that's
a recipe for witch cookies.
Just keep the claws in
tonight at the dance, OK?
I just fed her my blood.
No more hybrids
if she's a vampire.
You're better
than both of us.
I love her, Damon.
So do I.
The pentagram represents
our connection to magic.
Have a drink with me,
brother.
Please say
that you forgive me.
I never stopped loving you.
Our emotions
are what make us human.
Am I dead?
You did it.
I know it's hard.
See you in Gym.
You don't have to hide it.
I know you're not
going to hurt me.
You lost her?
Lost is a very strong word.
All I can think about
is killing vampires.
Saved by the cellphone.
Where is the cure?
I'm not crazy.
I'm just passionate.
Left or right?
I'll just chop off both
to be safe.
I would give anything
to be human.
We have to raise Silas.
It can bring Jeremy back.
People are going to start
asking questions.
I don't care.
It won't be fun,
but we're going to
cleanse you.
She's this close to going
off the rails for good
and that ain't happening.
I had to shovel my best
friend almost killed me.
None of this is OK!
I am immortal.
I got the girl.
I love you.
And I love you.
Where the hell am I?
The Other Side.
You've been dreaming
about Stefan all summer?
This is the…
the family crypt, huh?
Mm-hmm.
Damon, please.
I don't want to die.
I'm dead, Jer.
I need to know
that you're going to be OK.
I told you I knew
what I was doing.
It was the 1950s.
Am I supposed to remember
every moment of my life?
This is the worst day
of my life.
And I kind of totally
had sex with him.
I'm here
to kidnap your boyfriend.
If I can't have Stefan,
then no one can.
We've a lot of catching up
to do.
See you in class.
I need your help.
I think something's going on
on the other side.
Ouch.
Let's play a game called
Never Have I Ever.
Somebody help!
This is the last time
I'm going to see you.
What happened?
Where is everybody?
Will you marry me?
Oh my God!
Why didn't Bonnie
come back?
How do you feel?
Like you shot me
with an arrow.
My dad's trying to kill me.
It was a video journal.
What? No.
Journals are lame.
I've never felt more alive.
-We're losing her, Damon!
-No offence Elena
but we need to get
a real doctor.
-Kill her!
-Mortis!
Our lives are so weird.
That's the understatement
of the century.
I'm going to me all right,
Mum. I promise.
Hey, Elena, what...
She has
a really pretty neck.
You can't breathe.
I want to die.
What if the human you
doesn't love Damon
anymore?
Are you ready for this?
Elena told me
to keep a journal
of everything she's missing.
What do you think
about letting me use magic
to stop your heart?
This is necromancy.
Well, what better way
to spend Halloween, huh?
Quit torturing my brother
and tell me exactly
what's going on here.
He's unrecognisable.
Lily needs to go.
Incoming.
No! Lily!
I'm level-headed, Damon.
I only come out when Stefan
goes a little cuckoo.
While you were
working on me
Julian stole Stefan's body.
I am not raising my kids
anywhere near Mystic Falls.
If you hate Julian so much
can't you just go
kill him yourself?
No. That's not it.
No, because every time
Rayna dies,
she comes back stronger.
Make your choice.
I love you, brother.
Cut the crap, buddy.
No, I won't let you die,
Bonnie Bennett.
I'm trying to save
someone who hates me.
Which one?
No one's getting out.
Bonnie, please!
Did you raid a Cosplay
convention or something?
Damon.
Elena.
How many more bodies will
it take before this is over?
I think it was made in Hell.
I choose Enzo!
I'm trying to help
my brother.
Tyler Lockwood is dead.
And I'm not going to
lose you too.
I've got to say, you're
a man with a lot of guts.
I didn't have time
to poison it.
We can't seem
to go anywhere
without the past
coming back to haunt us.
I guess the inside
of Damon's head
looks a whole lot
like the outside.
You said you weren't going
to try anything stupid.
When did I ever
promise that?
-Enzo!
-Bonnie!
We're starting to slip back
into
H-E Double Hockey Sticks.
We don't know
what he'll do to Elena.
Damon.
Hello, brother.